[Musica]
io voglio iniziare con questa prima
diapositiva che vi dice una cosa molto
semplice cioè che la genetica sta
arrivando
sta arrivando non soltanto per gli
addetti ai lavori in cui è stata
confinata per tanti anni non sta
arrivando per me per tutti voi e per i
nostri figli e quindi è importante che
iniziamo a capire almeno la direzione in
cui si sta muovendo
io prima di venire qua o l'altra
settimana ho fatto un esperimento
semplicemente ho detto vediamo cosa c'è
non come ne parlano nei giornali della
di genetica e dell'ingegneria genetica o
trovate ovviamente l'articolo di stephen
king che postumo che dice che tra poco
noi saremo soppiantati da una specie
umana geneticamente modificata
ovviamente ho trovato putin che ognuno
secondo le sue sensibilità aveva paura
della creazione di supersoldati immagino
perché rivoglia solo lui ho cercato un
tweet del nostro vice ministro purtroppo
non l'ho trovato però la buona notizia
che vi posso dare è che nessuna di
queste due cose è molto facile che
avvenga e una in particolare quella di
tutti anche un po mi dispiace devo dirvi
la verità perché io sono un grande fan
della fantascienza e se qualcuno con
l'ingegneria genetica riuscissi a
creargli wonder woman e capitan america
io non avrei assolutamente niente da
ridire
però diciamo così dell'ingegneria
genetica come vedete non se ne stanno
occupando solo le persone che la
studiano ma per dire se ne occupa
l'economist dove c'è gente molto
intelligente inizia a capire le
implicazioni dell'ingegneria genetica
perché se io adesso da ciascuno di voi
che non vi conosco prendessi un po delle
vostre cellule e stress il vostro dna e
facessi un'analisi delle sequenze io già
potrei dire un sacco di cose potrei dire
che altezza avete più o meno potrei dire
il colore dei vostri occhi
il colore dei capelli
potrei dirvi anche cose che neanche voi
sapete fuori il per esempio potrei dirvi
se i vostri enzimi sono più adatti a
correre i 100 metri piuttosto che a fare
una maratona e ovviamente equa diciamo
così è la parte importante potrei dirvi
se siete rischio di sviluppare qualche
malattia cardiovascolare
neurodegenerativa di qualunque tipo
ora voi mi direte va bene ma no chi
sarebbe così matto da andare a
modificare geneticamente un essere umano
e qua
diciamo così c'è un po la brutta notizia
e cioè il fatto che noi come specie
siamo dei manipolatori noi se domani io
mettessi la un cartello con un bottone
rosso con sopra scritto assolutamente
non schiacciare una buona percentuale di
voi andrebbe lì a schiacciarlo per
vedere semplicemente che cosa succede e
e questo è sempre successo
ma voi sapete i bambini sono convinti
che le cosce di pollo nascano nella
vaschetta del supermercato però neanche
il pollo nasce diciamo così come pollo
perché quando il nostro antenato
neolitico entra in una radura non ha
trovato un branco di galline ovaiole suo
unico problema era come iniziare a fare
una frittata
ma le galline ovaiole vengono da una
specie di gallo cedrone e io vi posso
assicurare non solo un etologo ma andare
da una femmina di gallo cedrone cercare
di togliergli le uova non è
un'esperienza piacevole quindi noi
attraverso non sapevamo ovviamente che
cosa fare dal gallo cedrone abbiamo
avuto il polo abbiamo anche modificato i
vegetali che non modifichiamo tutto
quello che vediamo in natura non 12.000
anni fa l'inca entra in una valle e non
trova la pannocchia è di nuovo il suo
unico problema è come riesca a fare il
popcorn ma trova a quello
l'arbusto no che vedete la sulla
sinistra che si chiama teosinte poi
attraverso varie modificazioni riusciamo
ad avere la pannocchia allora diciamo
così noi stessi noi stessi ci siamo
modificati anche in un arco di tempo
abbastanza breve
voi vedete qua 100 mila anni fa siamo
tutti usciti dall africa
chi è andata a sinistra cosa trovato ha
trovato in under taliani e i
neandertaliani diciamo così oltre a
probabilmente averli portati anche
contribuito se non un altra loro
istruzione ci siamo diciamo così
accoppiati con i neandertaliani e tutti
in gran parte di noi che siamo in questa
sala
abbiamo circa dall 1 al 5 per cento di
dna di un'altra specie umana che è
l'uomo di neanderthal e adesso con la
genetica queste cose sono anche facili
da scoprire
guardate io con meno di 100 dollari
ho contattato una compagnia americana mi
sono fatto dire quanto è il mio dna
number taliano io adesso so che ho 269
varianti tipiche dei neanderthal e una
di queste varianti a che fare con
l'altezza quindi inutile che me la
prendo tanto con i miei genitori si sono
solo alto 170 mi doveva mai sarei dovuta
prendere con qualcuno che ha vissuto ben
molto tempo fa ora la genetica da dove
parte la genetica diciamo così la vera
genetica no come voi sapete qua non
voglio farvi venire in mente delle
brutti ricordi dei vostri tempi e al
liceo parte da mendel questo povero
monaco che nasce diciamo così
studia tutta la sua vita su come si
trasmettono i caratteri muore disperato
amore disperato perché nessuno riconosce
il valore le scoperte del 1860 in un
bellissimo monastero borno adesso fra in
mente la gente solo conoscere per il
motogp lui scopre che i caratteri si
possono trasmettere scopi caratteri
recessivi scopi caratteri dominanti e lì
inizia una enorme corsa inizia un enorme
corsa
i bellissimi libri a riguardo dove
sostanzialmente prima di tutto sia
andato a cercare la molecola che si è
scoperto il dna poi c'è la struttura del
dna di watson e crick di no ci sono
bellissimi libri che spiegano questo ma
subito come vedete appena sono state
fatte queste scoperte l'essere umano ha
cercato qualche maniera di sfruttarle e
quindi all'inizio degli anni 70 80
abbiamo lo sviluppo delle pmi delle
prime piante transgeniche
abbiamo la clonazione con la pecora
dolly che voi sapete adesso la prima
nazione umana è proibita però questo non
vuol dire che lo sarà in futuro è
proibita solo da noi e questa sono cose
che diciamo così devono iniziare a
destare qualche preoccupazione dopo
diciamo così l'altra data estremamente
importante per quello che riguarda
l'ingegneria genetica nel 2001 nel 2001
craig venter pubblica l'intera sequenza
nucleotide per nucleo tive del nostro
genoma
ora questa è stata una cosa che fatta la
prima volta è costata diversi milioni di
dollari diversi anni di ricerca
adesso il vostro intero dna di ciascuno
di voi si può sequenziare per un costo
di circa 1.000 dollari in tre mesi e
tutte quelle informazioni che io vi ho
fatto vedere all'inizio sono portate nel
vostro codice genetico
adesso in teoria sono libere di essere
sfruttata e guardate che negli stati
uniti lo stanno già facendo
tra poco arriva anche da noi ci sono
delle compagnie che si rivolgono alle
persone che si vogliono sposare dire va
bene ok
voi avete già deciso chi porta fuori a
spasso il cane spazzatura
chi mette le catene alla macchina
quando nevica vi piacete però perché non
data anche un attimo un'occhiata al
genoa il genoma del vostro partner e
guardati che questo può essere un
problema io no avevo sempre difficoltà a
trovare ragazzi mi mancava solo che
mentre no mi dicevano sì tu mi piaci
però adesso spunta in questa provetta e
tra tre settimane
no ti dico che va bene ma questo ma
questo è il futuro e il futuro che
stiamo avevamo incontro che ci piaccia o
non ci piace e ovviamente per certi
versi guardate le dico ci deve piacere
molto perché l'ingegneria genetica ha
risolto un sacco di malattie terribili e
la maniera che l'ha fatto è stato in una
maniera concettualmente molto semplice
cioè uno prende la cellula con il gene
malato dalla persona con un virus
gli mette dentro una copia del gene sano
riprende questa cellula rimette in
questa persona è la persona è guarita e
questo approccio è stato fantasticamente
di successo perché adesso quello che voi
vedete qua non entrò assolutamente nel
dettaglio ci sono decine di trattamenti
in europa che si basano su questo genere
di tecniche e che possono guarire
soprattutto bambini di malattie
veramente terribili quindi non tutto è
male diciamo così nella ricerca genetica
però c'è un aspetto che adesso vi dirò
che inserisce anche una piccola
preoccupazione e cioè questo genere di
manipolazioni sono manipolazioni
grossolane nel senso che chiunque a un
addetto ai lavori se manipola il dna in
questo genere di procedure gli altri lo
riescono a vedere è un po come se alla
vostra macchina si rompe un faro voi
andate dal ricambista comprato un altro
faro
e panna gliel'ho saldate sul cofano
per l'amor di dio la vostra macchina
funziona bene uguale la notte ma
chiunque specialmente il vigile urbano
no vede e dice no qualcuno ha manipolato
quello che succede adesso è che si
stanno sviluppando delle tecniche per
cui non esiste maniera di capire se un
genere stato manipolato meno vi farò
vedere sono tecniche molto complesse e
sono anche tecniche che in teoria
saranno molto utili perché dal punto di
vista terapeutico quello che si fa
adesso che si tenderà a fare adesso
prendere alla cellula con il gene malato
non mettergli un gene sano ma riparare
quel gene malato e oltretutto adesso ci
sono anche tecniche per cui uno può
riparare il gene malato può trasformare
la cellula in una cellula che gli serve
non so un neurone una cellula del fegato
una cellula del r'n'r impiantarla nel
paziente e quindi raggiungere efficienze
terapeutiche che prima semplicemente non
erano possibili
però c'è un problema di fronte a questo
grande vantaggio ovviamente chiunque nel
futuro abbia intenzione di cambiare il
dna può farlo senza lasciare traccia
e questo diciamo così che avverrà fra
non pochi anni rappresenta a mio avviso
un poco come quando è stata scoperta
l'energia atomica
quando è stata scoperta l'energia
atomica e subito è stata fatta la bomba
nucleare a nessuno sano di mente gli
sarebbe venuto da dire eh beh ma questa
è una cosa molto complicata lasciamola
solo gestire ai fisici ai militari
perché no le implicazioni dell'energia
atomica non riguardano solo i fisici
militari ma li guardano tutti noi il
futuro di tutti i nostri figli
e quindi queste tecniche di
manipolazione genetica che si stanno
sviluppando sempre di più adesso hanno
bisogno che ognuno di voi se ne faccia
un minimo di carico che parli con i
politici che parli con quelli che devono
decidere che cosa ha ammesso o meno e
che soprattutto facciano in modo che
tutte queste tecniche non vengano
utilizzate per degli scopi diciamo così
impropri
perché io vi voglio ricordare una cosa
io lavorano nell'ambito delle nazioni
unite sapete la si fanno tante riunioni
si cercano di risolvere tanti problemi
ma la prima lezione che ti dicono quando
tu decidi di lavorare per questo genere
organizzazione e ti dicono caro mio
mi raccomando cerca sempre di essere
seduti di essere seduto al tavolo in cui
si mangia perché altrimenti vuol dire
che farai parte del menu
grazie
[Applauso]